The Red Face Demon is an evil entity
who may be as ancient as time itself. It
resides in a netherworld, another plane
separate from the land of the living.
– [Specs] Does this other plane have a name?
– [Elise] Let’s call it… The Further.
– It’s possible that the demon came about
in the 1700s, which is when historians
believe the first modern carnival originated
in the Caribbean, because Insidious director
James Wan has described the demon’s
appearance as something out of a crazy,
mystical carnival. The tufts of hair protruding
from the side of the head and razor sharp teeth
do bear a resemblance to another terrifying
carnival entity from another plane of existence:
Pennywise. However, other demons in the franchise
have the ability to change their appearance,
so it’s possible that this demon is much older.
But Red Face’s confinement to The Further
would not last forever. One of the main
ideas expressed in the franchise is the inherent
risk that comes with exploring the other world.
– I’ve been to that dark place
too. It’s not a place for pure
souls. It is very dangerous. Things come back with you.
– [Zac] And I believe that’s exactly what
happened when psychic medium Elise
Rainier entered The Further in about
2007. I’m guessing the year based on
the fact that Insidious Chapter 3 takes
place a few years before the first film,
and the main character Quinn has a T-Mobile
Sidekick 3, which came out in July 2006.
Quinn’s family isn’t doing well, so it
makes sense she’d have last year's model.
Quinn ends up getting stranded in The Further
by another demon, and Elise has to come out of
retirement to rescue her. It seems that all is
well after this, but Elise does not immediately
realize what came back with her. She gets home
to find her late husband’s vest on the bed, and
at first, believes it was his spirit who placed
it there. Then she notices a face in the closet.
(dog barking)
(stinger)
To learn how this entity became attached to the
Lambert family, what the demon is supposed to
represent and how its presence can still be felt
today, stick around to the end of this video.
This video is sponsored by Factor.
(metal music)
Welcome to Horror History. Today
I’m analyzing what most people consider the
main antagonist of the Insidious franchise.
In the film, he’s referred to as The Man With
Fire on His Face, but in the end credits,
he’s tagged as Lipstick-Face Demon. However
this seems to be more of a nickname created
by the filmmakers because of the way that
the special effects makeup was applied.
– [Wan] The reason he’s called the Lipstick face demon
is because he literally paints
his face with a red lipstick.
– So many fans just refer to the character
as The Red Face Demon. In addition to the
Pennywise similarity I already mentioned,
Red Face seems to be an amalgamation of
the scariest parts of many horrors in
cinema. The obvious one that comes to
mind is Darth Maul from Star Wars: The
Phantom Menace, whose most iconic scene
takes place at the end of a hallway of red
light, not unlike the demon in Insidious.
Red Face also has long claw-like hands,
reminiscent of Freddy Krueger from A Nightmare
on Elm Street. Freddy is known for haunting
characters in their dreams, and before Dalton
learns about astral projection in Insidious,
he believes The Further to be a dream world.
The character also possesses a black body, a tail,
a forked tongue, and fur around his hooved feet,
giving off similarities to traditional
depictions of Satan. The Further is
stated to be a limbo that exists before
a ghost moves on, so it’s possible that
The Red Faced demon is supposed to be
The Further equivalent of The Devil.
The character is played by Joseph
Bishara. If that name sounds familiar,
it’s either because he’s also the composer of
the film’s score, or because you recognize him
from other roles he’s played, such as Bathsheba in
The Conjuring or Malthus in the Annabelle films,
both of which I’ve already covered
on Horror History. Who would have
thought a composer would be the most
frequent actor covered on this show?
To understand how his character
became attached to the Lambert family,
we’ve got to take it back to Elise’s
most personal investigation yet.
(ominous freaking music)
In 2010, a few years into Elise’s partnership with
Specs and Tucker of Spectral-Sightings.com, she’s
called back to her home town in New Mexico to deal
with a demon who haunted her all the way back in
her youth. It pulls her into The Further, but she
defeats it with the help of her mother and nieces.
Little does she know, they are being followed by
The Red Face demon, or something to that effect.
As they make their way out of the dark realm,
they take a wrong turn, and end up in The Further
version of the Lambert family’s attic. The Further
is not bound by time, meaning that wandering souls
can visit events from the past, and possibly the
future, although we’ve yet to see that happen.
Dalton Lambert is the son of Josh Lambert, who
Elise helped many years ago, and they see him
fall off an old ladder. But Elise doesn’t know who
he is yet, and thinks they’ve gone the wrong way.
From Dalton’s perspective in the
real world, he can’t see any of them,
but he does hear the crackling sound
emitted by the Red Face Demon.
(crackling sound)
The reason that The Red Face Demon has
stayed with Elise for the last few years
is because of her abilities as a medium.
Although she rarely uses it, she has the
ability to astral project. She can project her
spirit out of her body and into The Further. The
demon’s goal is to possess the bodies of the
living. Most non-living entities crave life,
but Elise later explains that this Demon wants
to possess a body simply to cause pain to others.
When the demon sees Dalton, it realizes that he
too has the ability to astral project, and sees
him as an easier target because of his naivety
as a kid. Dalton believes his astral projection
is just a fun dream, so he’s not afraid to venture
deep into The Further, thus leaving his body as an
open vessel for an evil spirit to try to possess.
Because of this, Red Face sticks with Dalton,
and coaxes him further and further into The
Further. See, that’s why they call it that.
Each demon or major evil entity has their
own space in The Further behind a red door,
and these doors can connect different
locations & time periods. Red Face puts
a door to his lair right in The Lamberts’
attic, essentially replacing the connection
between their California home and Elise’s
New Mexico home that used to be there.
Perhaps because he was curious
about the noise he heard there,
and perhaps partially because he’s been
banned from the attic in real life,
he visits the location in what he thinks
is his dream, and goes far enough into the
demon’s lair to discover this horse statue,
which he draws a picture of when he wakes up.
Dalton also sees Red Face at some point
and draws pictures of him as well,
in addition to the red doors. This picture
shows it standing at the semicircle shaped
window next to the spinning machine
that it uses to sharpen its claws.
It’s possible that Dalton was at
first intrigued by this brightly
colored new friend, and went deeper
and deeper into The Further to try to
get a look at him. Director James Wan and
screenwriter Leigh Whannel allude to the
idea that his appearance is supposed
to be inviting to children at first.
– [Wan] It’s kind of like a clown. It’s his twisted
way of trying to make himself look like a
good happy person to try to entice you to him.
– [Whannel] He’s the one who’s out there trying to suck
in the spirits of innocent people, especially
children; try and get them out of their bodies,
draw them out into The Further so he
can then go in and inhabit their body.
– In my opinion, it didn’t work. He’s just straight
up terrifying, but this is a horror movie,
and that’s a good thing. The music he listens
to also plays into the idea that he’s trying
to entice Dalton. His favorite song is
“Tiptoe Through the Tulips” by Tiny Tim.
You can imagine a kid being drawn in by the
silly falsetto vocals and ukulele strums,
but once you get into the demon’s lair and hear it
echoing through an empty realm of tortured souls,
you start to realize, “oh yeah, this song is
creepy AF.” In an interview with The Film Stage,
James Wan refers to it as “serial killer music.”
It would not be long before Dalton began
referring to these “dreams” as “nightmares”,
and eventually he’d find himself in one
nightmare he could not wake up from.
(real big impact sound)
Food. I eat it. You eat it. Some people even blog
it. But cooking healthy meals can be expensive
and take a lot of time. The solution is the
get Factor! Not only is factor cheaper than
takeout, but meals are ready quicker than
restaurant delivery — in just 2 minutes!
They deliver the meals right to your door,
so you don't even have to think about making
a trip to the store. Their registered
dietitians work hand-in-hand with their
kitchen to ensure every meal is made from
scratch with nutritious ingredients. Your
meal is delivered fresh—never frozen—to
your door. Just heat, eat, and enjoy!
Amp up your Factor order with add-ons
like proteins, juices, energy bites,
veggie sides, desserts, and more. And don’t worry,
Factor’s snacks and desserts accommodate
those following plant based and keto diets.
I've been enjoying HelloFresh unsponsored
for over a year, so when Factor reached
out and I found out they're owned by
HelloFresh, I knew I had to try it,
and it ended up being perfect for me, it tastes
great, and it saves me time... which I guess I
am now using that time to shoot and edit this ad
read... But it will save me time in the future!
Head to FACTOR75 dot com or click
the link below and use code CZ60 to
get 60% off your first Factor box! Who else
gives 60% off? Just use code: CZ60 to save.
(suspenseful music)
Josh and Renai Lambert have just moved into
their new home with their three children when
strange things start to occur. In reality, I can’t
tell you if The Red Face Demon is responsible,
or if it was just one of the many ghosts attracted
to Dalton, seeking a human body to inhabit.
Something moves some of Renai’s books, there’s
a breathing sound heard in the house (which may
just be a draft), a furnace turns on in
the attic all on its own, and the attic
door opens without anyone touching it. That one
probably was the demon, trying to lure Dalton
up the stairs. Renai’s sheet music also goes
missing and she finds it in that same attic.
Finally, the ladder breaks under
Dalton, and although he’s OK at first,
the next morning he doesn’t wake up. In reality,
the fall is not what hurt him. That night he went
too deep into the demon’s lair and was captured
and chained up to some kind of demonic shrine.
With him trapped in The Further, the demon,
or any of the other spirits that have shown
up at the house would have an opportunity
to take possession of the vacant vessel.
Three months go by, and Dalton still appears
to be in a coma. He’s living at home off
of IVs. Renai is working downstairs when
she hears something in the baby monitor.
(whispers)
– (whispered) He won't wake up.
There’s nothing you can do.
– [Zac] The voice says “he won’t wake up. There’s
nothing you can do.” Again, it isn’t clear
if this is Red Face himself, or one of the other
spirits. What is clear, is what this voice wants.
– I want it.
Kill.  Kill.
I want it. I want it! NOW!
– The Lamberts’ other son, Foster, becomes
afraid of rooming across the hall from Dalton,
because he claims that his brother is walking
around at night, which is most likely a result
of the demon, who can be invisible in the real
world, puppeting his body around the house.
They also find red handprints on Dalton’s sheets,
with long pointed fingers. Nick Cave and The
Bad Seeds would have had a field day with this.
When Red Face first discovers the
unoccupied body, Elise sees it in her dream.
(JUMP SCARE)
In the real world, handprints manifest
themselves on the window. Convinced that
their house is haunted, The Lamberts move again,
but the spirits that haunt the place follow
the scent of Dalton’s uninhabited self, and the
paranormal activity continues in the new house.
As Renai is taking the trash out,
the evil creature changes her music to
something a little more to its liking.
♪ piano music ♪
(record scratch)
♪ Tiptoe, through the window, by the window… ♪
The grandmother comes to the house and sees
strange things as well. One night she had a
dream, which was really an out of
body experience into The Further,
where she saw the demon in silhouette
while checking on Dalton in his room.
It told her that it was a visitor, and when
she asked what it wanted, it pointed to Dalton.
The next day when telling the story to Josh and
Renai, Red Face makes a more direct appearance.
(demonic roar) (scream)
It disappears into Dalton’s room and locks the
door shut as it tears through everything, leaving
the place in complete disarray with the comatose
boy laying on the ground when they regain entry.
Having seen enough, they call in Elise,
Specs and Tucker. They bring in something
called a tri-field meter, and Tucker picks
up The Red Face Demon’s cracking noises.
(cracking sounds)
Then again outside of Foster’s room.
And when Elise visits Dalton’s room, she hears
the noises coming from right above his bed.
(cracking sounds)
Being the only one able to see the
monster, she describes it to Specs,
who sketches something very similar to
Dalton’s drawings, and is also really
creepy. After seeing it potentially
speaking to Renai on the baby monitor,
appearing IRL behind Josh, and allowing the
paranormal investigators to make a sketch,
I don’t think Red Face fears the humans, even
Elise who has the power to see what it’s up
to. It’s certainly different from James Wan’s
other demon-hunting franchise, The Conjuring,
where we see the entities try to hide themselves
from the paranormal investigating protagonists.
Red Face has probably never faced a formidable
foe, and has no reason to be scared of humans,
plus Elise is portrayed to be much less
super-hero-ey than Lorraine Warren,
and Specs and Tucker combined are still probably
a jack of less trades than Ed Warren is.
For these reasons, I like these investigators
way more, but that’s neither here nor
there. Elise explains the nature of
Dalton’s coma in the now famous line…
– It’s not the house that’s
haunted.
It’s your son.
– She goes onto explain that many nearby entities
can smell the open vessel that is Dalton’s body,
but the demon is the only one who
is *very* close to possessing him.
The team sets up cameras around where they’ll
be performing a séance, and seem to connect
with the boy’s spirit, but he stops talking
when the demon notices what he’s up to,
and eventually claims that if The Man With Fire
on His Face hears him, he’s going to hurt him,
and not long after, the evil entity hijacks the
communication and berates Elise with obscenities,
threatening to rip her innards out
and eat the guts that spill from her.
For the first time in months, Dalton moves.
He appears to sleepwalk over to the group
and smack the table, effectively air yeeting
everyone in its vicinity. He also smacks Specs,
sending him flying across the room into
a wall. While it would appear that Dalton
has been possessed to do these things, one of
the still frames eventually reveals that the
Red Face Demon was only standing behind
the boy, essentially puppeting his body.
It takes time for an entity of The
Further to actually possess somebody,
and Red Face was at the doorstep, but not
quite there. Regardless, Elise’s retaliation
seemed to do the trick for the time being, and
the demon retreated to its lair to presumably
sharpen up its claws one last time before making
an ultimate attempt at taking over Dalton’s body.
An interesting detail about the lair, is the
demon’s collection of marionettes, which are
likely symbolic of the way Red Face puppeteered
Dalton’s body during the séance. It seems
it was able to do this convincingly because it
practiced to become an expert using these puppets.
The lair is also decorated with gothic revival
architecture, featuring great chandeliers and
candelabras, roman looking statues everywhere,
gargoyles, a low lying fog, and giant masks
looking upwards. The scene was filmed in the
Harold Examiner building in downtown Los Angeles,
one of the few examples of 100 year old
architecture that still maintains a sheen
of luxury. Perfect for this demon, who is both
ancient and powerful among the world of demons.
But the demon’s netherworldian manicure is
interrupted when it notices the spirit of
Josh Lambert, who has projected into
The Further to try to save his son,
and the interruption of the Further’s most
nefarious creature would not be welcome.
(el impacto)
(tense music)
After finding out why his son refers
to this demon as The Man With Fire
In His Face first hand, he’s air yeeted
across the room by the creature’s screech,
but the distraction allows Dalton, now free
from his chains, to escape. The demon can be seen charging and
knocking Josh down a second time, he gets to
his feet, scoops up his son and runs for it,
leaving The Red Faced Demon to track
them with its piercing yellow eyes.
This battle was not over and it’s ferocity was
shaking the entire house back in the real world.
The father and son find themselves surrounded
by wandering spirits, having called too much
attention to themselves, and Josh uses the last of
his energy to get them back to the house. Unable
to go on, he stops to rest as tell Dalton to go
on ahead to return to his own body, but before the
boy can get there, he’s ambushed by his demonic
captor, who is waiting for him in his room.
Dalton flees to his parents room, but Red
Face once again teleports through The Further,
this time emerging under the bed
to try to drag the child under,
but he wiggles free and runs down the hall.
Red Face then unleashes more of his power, by wall
crawling out of the room, the drywall crumbling
with each step he takes, but he’s unable to
recapture Dalton who makes it back to his physical
body, closing the door on any chances of being
possessed. The only other available vessel then,
is Josh, who does get partially possessed by
another entity known as The Bride in Black,
leaving no available landing spot for the
demon with the red face. He can’t even go back
to stalking Elise, because she is killed by The
Bride in Black, so her body is no longer of use.
With this development, Red Face seems to just
give up on the Lambert family and move onto
a new target, a girl named Allison, who also had
the ability to astral project. Allison was in some
kind of accident and had to be resuscitated
at the hospital, but while she was out,
she seemingly ventured into The Further, and
brought The Red Face Demon back with her.
After helping The Lambert family clear
out their evil spirits a second time,
Specs and Tucker visit Allison’s family to try
to offer assistance, with Elise tagging along
as a spirit in The Further. When Elise tries to
elicit a response from Allison, she seems to be
as empty of a shell as Dalton once was, and
it’s not long before Elise figures out why…
(cracking sound)
– Oh my God…
(gasp)
– [Zac] Elise recognizes that sound from the haunting that
resulted in her losing her own
life. The battle was not over.
The upcoming Insidious: Fear the Dark (aka:
Chapter 5) will supposedly catch up with the
Lambert family 10 years later. As much as scary
ghosts + scary virus sounds like a terrifying
combination, I am going to be very frustrated if
we don’t get a follow up on this cliff-hanger.
However if we do see Darth Maul’s lost cousin
again, I’ll be sure to update this video. Make
sure you don’t miss that, or any of my
other Insidious character analysis’ by
subscribing to CZsWorld for new horrors
every week, ringing that death bell for
all notifications and I will see you in
the next one. Assuming we both survive.
(urban music)